operate in real world context at 300
transactions per second with 2 to 3
seconds for confirmation of
transactions that's faster than Visa
that's faster with greater capacity than
Visa this is the beginning of a real
global system that can actually work
that can deliver upon the promise that
can take us to a point where we're
actually seeing different businesses
commercial opportunities evolve and
emerge on blockchain that begin to
transform the nature of our
economy I'm going to pass across to the
rest of the team now uh and just
introduce them briefly as I do UL VGA is
uh one of the the leading lights in the
blockchain sorry in the erlang world um
he's been an Erlanger since
1992 and for that reason was vital to
making all of these pieces work uh Craig
Everett came on board as the chief
product officer Craig is somebody who's
been working in distributive Computing
and Computing systems for a very long
time delivering Real World products and
real world solutions for customers and
Dimitar a crypto OG who has been in this
space since the beginning developing
Solutions working on cryptographic
principles and consensus algorithms and
with that I will pass over to Dimitar to
initiate today's
demo okay okay I'll share my
screen
um okay uh what you see here in the back
is uh the chain Explorer uh it shows
real time how the chain is changing so
every transaction that goes on the Chain
will show up here and that's what I'm
going to show you I open my wallet uh
this is the amount of gajar coins I have
and I'm going to send a few to crack uh
this is his address and I'm going to
send
42 I can uh type a short message so we
can see that this the same transaction
uh well it's not his birthday today but
let's uh say
happy
day uh now when I see uh click Send uh
here uh a new block is going to get
created that includes that transaction
uh but it's going to be really fast so
I'm sending that and here is the
transaction uh once I click it we can
see it says happy birthday and 42 gaj
marus this is still proof of work and
how this works I'm going
to ask o to
explain yes so the protocol we're using
is called Bitcoin NG NG for Next
Generation it was originally imagined as
a way to increase the throughput of
Bitcoin so it's based on the same idea
in Bitcoin miners compete to solve a
puzzle calibrated to take about 10
minutes to
solve uh The Miner that solves the
puzzle gets to produce one block on the
Chain um now this gives roughly 3 to
five transactions per second through put
and up to 10 minutes response time if
the system isn't over uh congested which
it often is so and then it can take a
lot
longer uh also it gives very high
transaction cost for that reason because
if you want to get included faster you
have to raise the fee and bribe the
miners in Bitcoin and G the difference
is the minor that solves a POS
and for us it's calibrated to take about
3 minutes to solve becomes the leader
and can produce blocks until another
minor comes up with a solution for a
puzzle and uh these blocks are called
micro blocks and are packed with
transactions and come uh roughly two to
three seconds apart or immediately if
the the chain is idle and a traction
transaction pops up this gives us very
high
throughput up to 300 transactions per
second and response times of up to 2 3
seconds normally before your transaction
is on
chain um now what Dimitar demonstrated
was a spend transaction which is the
cheapest form of transaction uh we also
have Smart contracts like ethereum does
but unlike ethereum we have a smart
contract language that that is designed
by some worldclass programming language
designers it's very robust it's designed
partly specifically to
fix most of the known security flaws in
the solidity programming language it has
a very efficient virtual machine
allowing us to also execute smart
contracts very efficiently on
chain so with that over to
Craig thanks wol uh the so my
perspective on this is both on the
technical side working in for
development but also on the product side
having tried to build things on
blockchain for real for several years
and having been foiled by the
limitations of blockchain consistently
uh super super annoying um
what we see in ethereum and Bitcoin is
uh proof of concept systems that uh they
proved their point the Nakamoto paper
about distributed consensus and uh how
that could be used and a proof of work
sense to um create and protect a create
a currency that's digital in nature and
is not debase by any single Authority uh
that's great Bitcoin proves that that
work but it only barely proves that it
can work it's not a prod it's not robust
enough to to be the basis for a product
series um ethereum same problem in terms
of
throughput but that project did prove
that you could use the state of a
blockchain as the backend for an ongoing
State machine uh the execution context
of programs could be the state on that
blockchain and so on excellent uh
however like many proofs of concept uh
there's a lot of gaps there there's huge
pitfalls um there's pitfalls in the evm
that are so bad that uh you can't you
can't prove anything about a contract on
ethereum uh heavily AED contracts always
have security balls in them but it's
it's crazy I'm glad that that work
happened it's fantastic it happened but
that needed to get cleaned up um before
you could build anything real on top of
it so from a product perspective um I'm
really excited about this uh this is the
direction that blockchain should have
gone a decade ago but we got distracted
by the you know the hold old Bros and
the big number go up crazy speculation
stuff where everybody was looking for a
get money Rich you know get-rich quick
kind of windfall profit thing instead of
looking at business models and what is a
business model how do you make money how
do you provide a value they're just
trying to you
know catch money while it's falling out
of the sky so to speak which is not
sustainable at all
um in that vein qq's perspective and the
reason I'm here uh with qpq is that um
we've got a bunch of different ideas of
businesses that we want to build on a
blockchain to do that though we need a
blockchain that works and there aren't
any so qpq From pq's perspective it
would have been great if there was
already an awesome blockchain out there
but there aren't any uh so we had to
solve that problem first and we wish we
could have avoided it because it was
really really hard um however that work
being done um we can move on and start
productizing things uh Building Products
on top of this this is the direction
that we again we should have gone 10
years ago uh didn't happen that way now
we're finally making up for kind of lost
time in that sense and uh um qpq yes is
operating a blockchain the business
models though are screet business models
the blockchain itself is not the
business model there are of course
upsides to being the operator of
blockchain because you're first mover
and so on but windfall profits as I said
before they are not business models um
so anyway this is where we're supposed
to be thank goodness very happy about
that uh the the the low latency this
idea the design principle of Bitcoin and
G where you have proof of work the proof
of the work being separated from the
work of Ledger updates and inclusion um
that's a very clean very natural
separation of concerns it should have
been obvious years ago nobody picked up
on that so whatever we are um this is
where we're supposed to be that low
latency lets us do things like retail
level transactions on chain which is
awesome so very excited about this uh if
uh drg's got something to say on the way
out um we're just super happy that this
is finally
happening and you're
muted thank you to everybody and uh
again I'm muted so uh back on stage
um yeah look I've been working at this
for 22 years now um the idea of how to
build a new economic system that
everybody can participate in everybody
can join into
um and how we can begin to use that as a
tool to create an economy in which we
can all participate these have all been
things I've been working at for a very
long time um I never thought I'd have to
actually build the blockchain you know
when I started this again in 2017 it was
because I'd seen the emergence of direct
to day cyclic graphs and thought they
could actually achieve some of the or
solve some of the problems that that I
saw in the existing systems actually
they didn't really do that and by and
large they ended up becoming evm driven
systems and they had all of the same
flaws and problems that come with
solidity and EVMS um
so my constant bug bear has been that
this is an industry replete with proof
of Concepts that really haven't evolved
to become minimum viable products never
mind fully commercialized products this
is why we have a constant discussion
about how we get the other 99% of the
world to start using cryptographic
instruments currencies and blockchain
it's going to stay 99% until something
like the gajim Maru comes along that
says hey you know what we're actually
going to give you the scalability and
the throughputs and the security and the
certainty that is necessary in order to
be able to do the basic but incredible
thing that blockchains allow us to do
which is to trust the message not the
messenger securely at
scale we have never I have never nobody
on this on this demo has ever been party
to the number go up game I've never
released a white paper in all the years
I've been doing this to talk about how
somebody can give me money so that I can
build something that may or may not work
and the object as everybody knows in the
background is just a have the number go
up and some poor people to be left
holding the
back I've taken that Hard Road because I
think the Integrity of this is important
I think this technology offers us an
opportunity to change
everything and we need to do it the
right way for the right reasons in the
right way and that's exactly what we've
done here um I it was just not possible
to achieve all the things I want to be
able to do with blockchains until we had
a fun functioning
blockchain the amount of heavy lifting
you need to be able to do that is
phenomenal and and I've been
extraordinarily lucky to have met these
gentlemen and manag to bring them back
together with with what we're doing in
qpq and actually deliver a blockchain
that accomplishes all of these things so
this is the first of a number of demos
the next one will be looking at how we
can enable market
operations we'd love to talk to people
who want to build something on
blockchain but maybe have found that the
existing Services don't offer the things
that they need uh whether that's using
the mentor or or an associate proof of
work chain or sorry forgive me proof of
stake
chain um get in touch and thank you for
listening
bye-bye